Since the mid-September release of the South Korean series Squid Game on Netflix,...
...over 132 million people around the world have started watching the show.
According to Bloomberg, no other Netflix project has become so popular so quickly.
The nine-episode series is about a world where children's games turn deadly.
People who are deeply in debt play to win a giant cash prize,...
...but in these games, the loser dies.
Despite its dark content, the show was an instant hit.
It's a relatively new thing for Americans to enthusiastically embrace a foreign TV show.
For so long, Americans were really known for almost their stubborn,...
...aggressive adherence to not consuming product made in another country.
We exported all of our movies and our music and our TV shows,...
...but very few things came the other way.
It's still unclear whether there will be a second season of Squid Game.
Neither the show creators nor Netflix representatives have made any statements yet.
But since Netflix's profits for the show reached about 900 million dollars,...
...it seems to make sense, at least, financially.
Karina Bafradzhian for VOA News, Washington.